in lineups where Murray's not in the
game and then they've got to make some
adjustments in their pick and roll game
when jokic is up against Booker and
Durant and get better shots out of that
Booker on the floater
at 34 in game one here is Booker he got
it
you have those nights Booker using his
strength took it right to Caldwell poke
here's Porter Jr the Euro the kick and
it was to Payne
just opportunity for the Nuggets now
Booker alone cut it
that means Ross and it could also mean
TJ Warren
Booker voice
[Applause]
[Music]
Edge the top seeded nuggets Walker he
got it 14 and a quarter for Devin Booker
here's Booker
nuzzling in and hitting again Devin
Booker with 16 in the quarter good
health there defensively by Craig and an
excellent box out from Landry shaman on
Nicola jokic as Devin Booker gets to the
rim again book her away with it three on
two developing Booker Bates James
oh my what a shot from Devin Booker able
to bounce back
and even things up with the Lakers no
that's going to be a fun series to watch
but I think this one is the one that all
eyes are going to be on right now
because only nine points for the Denver
Nuggets here in the second quarter game
one that's where the Denver Nuggets
actually exploded outscoring a 19-37
right now this is the Phoenix Suns
second quarter Booker you bet Kevin
Durant and Devin Booker to scoots
amongst themselves so making his
presence felt but also allowing everyone
else to do their thing
[Music]
here's Booker at 27 in the first half
you have to score in this third Booker
has scored now
Aaron Gordon with his first field goal
of the game had been 0-5 from the floor
[Applause]
Booker he got it everything looks pure
he started
[Music]
jittering into the paint Booker oh my
that is ridiculous
well we get that answer from Steve Javi
our officiating expert Steve what'd you
see there guys I'll tell you what a heck
of a call here this is too it's a really
difficult situation here Durant doubled
finds Booker on the Move he's got it
40 43 for Devin Booker
hooker
slicing through pubs it up and in
45 for Devin Booker
[Applause]